the titans have overcome a heck of a lot
and they are now your eight win team
lone 8 win team in the afc they're your
top seed in the fc by a game and a half
over the ravens
and uh joining us right now on the
mercedes-benz van phone line is one of
the best in the business an all-pro and
a pro bowler and he is joining us fresh
off of that big win at home against the
new orleans saints kevin bayern here on
the rich eisen show how are you kevin
i'm doing well how you doing rich thanks
for having me thank you for coming on
this program um so what makes your team
tick
the way that it ticks kevin
i don't know man i think just the
culture that we have here in tennessee
uh
i think we're just blue collar guys you
know we obviously don't have all the
the hype or maybe support of of national
media and i think we kind of relish in
that and i think we just go out there
and just handle our business like our
kind of our mantra for this year is kind
of like you know we're not trying to
prove
anybody wrong or you know prove the
doubt is wrong we're just trying to
prove ourselves right and we just keep
doing what we're doing and uh just
trying to keep stacking wins so what do
you do right then kevin
other than just put w
[Laughter]
other than hang w's i'm trying to get
i'm trying to get into you know the
philosophy of this team and what makes
it work right as well as it does you
know
well obviously um uh you know we talk
about all the injuries and stuff like
that i think i've just seen a stat where
you know we've had like the most players
play for our team
in in the league this year where like 80
guys had suited up for us we're almost
like nfl record you know like i said the
culture that we have here just a next
man up mentality like obviously deer
gets hurt which is you know that's kind
of that's our mvp you know we feel like
you know he was the front-runner winning
mvp he goes down we bring in ap and we
understand that other guys just got to
step up and i think that's just the way
we're built and that's kind of how we
handle things and uh we don't do a lot
of things to beat ourselves and
you know obviously we've knocked down
some some some pretty good opponents
these past few weeks and uh just every
single week it's just a new challenge a
new challenge is not like you know we
get too caught up on one victory uh we
just keep going and keep rolling so
that's just our mentality when did it
first you know start i guess this year
because we all know as i mentioned in
the introduction to our chat here uh
kevin bayer here on the rich island show
the uh misstep and that might be
understating it against the arizona
cardinals in week one was it that
overtime comeback w in seattle and that
long flight home maybe that was more
celebratory than it looked like it could
possibly be in the third quarter or
second quarter of that game
is that it for you no i mean
i mean honestly that game was obviously
a big game on the road in a hostile
environment in seattle which is a pretty
good win for us but honestly we go into
every single game feel like we can win
we didn't know the first week was a bad
performance on on our end on all
accounts but i honestly would say
after we lost to the jets uh in our
minds we was pretty sick about it
especially at the end of the game uh we
feel like we really let one get away
from us and i said it in the media in
the press conference after the game like
you know we'll find out what type of
team we are after taking a loss to the
jets a team that we felt like when we do
we should have beat and um i i guess we
figured that out since then i mean uh
we've been able to stack wins since then
and you know i think that's just kind of
that was like a defining moment early in
the year at least to know hey we put
this stuff on film we'll get beat by
anybody in this league but we also had
other examples that you know we put this
stuff on film we'll beat anybody and i
think we've been doing that a lot more
of lately yeah stacking wins for sure
you haven't lost since that game six
straight wins and the last five
bills
chiefs colts rams
saints they all have one thing in common
they made the playoffs last year you're
beating teams
that had significant 20 20 seasons and
hopes for 2021 do you think you keep
laying down markers here
on these teams
kevin yeah i mean i don't yeah honestly
we just look at it like it's just the
next next domino that needs to fall on
our schedule we don't look at it like
you know obviously we understand teams
are great i think coaches do a great job
of getting us prepared as far as with a
great game plan understanding the keys
that we're going to have to accomplish
to have these victories because every
single every single game every single
week is different in this league that
teams have different players different
ways they want to beat you how they're
going to attack you so you have to go
into every single game as a separate
thing you know you have to prepare the
same way every single week don't get too
caught up on oh this team has a bad
record the team has a good record we
have to go out there you know and try to
beat every single team but you know i
just think just like i said man the way
this team is built man we're really just
we're confident uh we understand that
confidence doesn't breed success or
guarantee success but we also understand
that you know we have we feel like we
have great players we might not have the
the superstars and and the you know the
famous people other than my guy derek
but uh other than that we just go out
there and just try to win ball games
it's not about that it's about you know
when your number's called go out there
and make plays i think lawn will be very
upset that you don't call him famous
kevin
he might i mean you know he's got his
bus without a without a motor you know
he and compton have got the the uh the
the pod you know what i mean like i
think he hasn't been able to be on there
that often man he's you know he's been
on the team you know getting wins and
you know i'm still cool with will
compton and uh okay i'm kind of jealous
i feel like they need to bring me back
on the bus brought me on the bus one
time i was one of the original
interviews too so you helped them i had
to have a chat with it you helped that
boss that you helped that boss with no
motor get off the ground i i know hey
man sure i'm gonna eat some stock i'm
gonna have to highlight oh well we gotta
negotiate something well
i got kevin byrd here on the rich
housing show how how much does
give me something about vrabel that that
he has set the tone as your coach as the
hc
of the tennessee titans and having been
in there and done that as a player
obviously um and what what cachet he
brings to the table for you every week
well just like you said the fact that he
was obviously a super bowl winner as a
player
you know 14-year career
you know i think that
when it comes to players and the coaches
in relationship having a guy that's done
it that's been there you know that's
been in those meetings been in the
training room been injured he's pretty
much been through all the stuff that any
player can can go through it's so it's
so easy to relate it's so easy to
understand and buy into the things that
he's he's saying
but also i think just him coming up
under bill belichick with that new
england mindset you know i think that's
just kind of it's easy for guys to buy
in and he does a great job every single
week like i said he treats every week
differently it's not like you know
obviously we do have the similar same
team uh messages right if it's playing
with great effort and all those type of
things but every week is different he
does a great job early in the week just
preparing us getting our minds locked in
for each opponent and um
and this is my opinion and
he might be a little bit mad that i'm
going to say this but i think he should
be up for coach of the year just the job
that he's done this year with like i
just mentioned earlier with the injuries
we've had with all the different moving
parts that we've had to keep the team
and you know keeping us all together
keeping us locked in you know i think uh
he's got my vote for coach of the year
for sure you know what and kevin we we
did just last week a mid-season awards
you know that nobody it's it's a fake
award but you know that's what we do
here on a show like this i i i had
vrabel as my coach of the year that's
the national media that doesn't pay
attention to you and has you on the show
you know i'm just trying to pump my own
self for the heisman right here
kevin with you i believe it i'm good man
you're on to something man you know i am
and i think he's you know it looks like
he works himself into drills though does
he do that does he
looks like he might want to do that
right now he does actually like in
practice especially when i obviously my
very first guy here a few years ago um i
think it was like one of the first
couple of practices and he's over there
with the defensive lineman with the pad
on his chest
and he's doing drills with him and like
you know
guys are hitting him and he's like you
know you got gotta really extend and i'm
like this dude is crazy get his glasses
knocked off and everything but it was
just i think it was just one of those
things like man he's really involved in
every single point like offense defense
special teams he's in the drills doing
it with you you know what i'm saying
because that's pretty cool in my opinion
so like i said it's easy to buy into the
to the stuff that he's teaching kevin
byrd here on the rich eisen show from
the tennessee titans let's talk about
you a little bit here kevin we talked
about your team quite a bit um you first
came to my attention kevin bayerd um not
just with your play
but you calling out dion sanders on
twitter for not knowing your name
you went you went at you went with the
one of the all-time goats
and i thought okay
you've got some gumption you remember
that obviously right you're chuckling
absolutely
what happened for those for the walk us
through for those who might not recall
you going back and forth with at dion
sanders on twitter yeah back in the day
yeah it was a while ago i think this was
after my second year obviously i had a
great year that year eight interceptions
uh went first team all pro and all that
good stuff and
i think it was uh obviously dion was on
nfl network at the time and i think they
was asking him like who is the best who
who does he think is the best safety nfl
or something like that and obviously me
being a young player
uh i think he said uh tyrone matthews
who i feel like is one of the best
staters in nfl sure and i'm just a young
player i'm like you know how did you i
think i tweeted at him where i just made
a tweet and i was like how do you come
up with that
you know the best safety without naming
the first team all pro safety today and
i think it was like me and harrison
smith or something and you know he ended
up tweeting back and saying something
like you know
i pretty much i know who everybody
thinks was the best and you know
some to the extent of pretty much i'm
continuing to be the man and you
continue to be a fan
and
look obviously i've seen it i'm like
does he not know that i actually play in
the nfl like does he think that i'm just
like legit like like somebody that's
just
fooling him or something like that big
titans
yeah so i tweeted back like
you know i i don't remember exactly what
i too don't want to get it wrong but i
just said something like you know
obviously i'm a player in this league
and i'm not necessarily saying that i am
the best but i'm going to prove and i'm
going to work hard so i am the best and
that's my goal to end up being the best
then
and we know twitter just end up doing
this thing and it went viral and it was
you know i remember it was crazy but you
think about it the thing that i always
wanted to say was obviously i highly
respect
deion sanders and his career and the man
that he is and everything he's doing it
was just one of those deals where i was
just like i said being a young player
you know it's like you know give me my
respect you know what i'm saying that's
kind of oh yeah
you're the mayor of murphy what murphy
murphree's bro
okay i got that right murfreesboro from
middle tennessee state right i mean and
so you're making your name in this
business and you're sitting around
watching nfl network which means you
make a smart choice
and you're sitting there and you're
seeing dion talk about who the the best
safety is in the league and you don't
hear your name and you're like you know
i'm gonna grab my phone i'm gonna tell
him who's who and i
we we saw that we saw that kevin we saw
that man and we were like okay he's
going right at prime minister and that
was great
that was great you know as i'm older now
as a player you know that type of stuff
you know you know people vote you know
people gonna have their favorites that's
just what it is i mean you have some
people that go to
like obviously you went to michigan your
favorite quarterback of all time might
be tom brady
based upon that yes and it just you know
people have their favorites and stuff
like that and me as a player now i've
accomplished a lot in this league so far
and i still feel like i don't get the
recognition that i deserve but at the
end of the day you know that type of
stuff doesn't matter i can only control
what i can control i'm just trying to
help my team get wins and if i get
accolades along the way cool great but
at the end of the day you know my
family's healthy i'm healthy don't have
too much to complain about knock on wood
no doubt about that and look look dion
does go way back with uh with tyron
matthew back to you know absolutely
counseling him out of the honey bad
honey badger days into the nfl and
things like that but and you're you're
currently what where does he rank right
now chris on the pff uh safety list
kevin is the number one safety recording
the pro football focus okay there you go
and so these are these are the metrics
that that you're putting up uh do you
got and so and before leaving you before
we return to the team uh most important
stuff is the stuff that you're doing uh
with your wife the bayern family legacy
fund tell me about that what are you up
to with that
kevin yeah so the buyer family legacy
fund is a foundation me and my wife
started a couple years ago
obviously we felt like god has given so
much to us and given us so much grace we
wanted to be able to extend that uh to
people that you know obviously or maybe
go fall along tough times or whatever
the case may be we have a lot of because
i was already doing a lot of stuff in
the community already but i felt like i
wanted to be able to put some together
whereas though we can have yearly
activities from you know i have back to
school events i have uh we have a
thanksgiving event coming up as well so
if you want to
look up or try to check in with all this
stuff and check out for updates you can
go to
buyerfamilylegacy.org we'll have a
christmas event going on this year but i
also host a football camp every summer
so you know just a lot of stuff going on
i have a lot of initiatives i like to
work on i tend to do stuff year round um
so like i said man just like to be able
to help out anybody that's in that's a
need because like i said god has
extended so much grace in my life so we
want to be able to do the same two
beautiful babies right eliana and kevin
junior if i'm not correct
kevin actually he's the fourth actually
oh okay kevin the fourth fourth okay iv
uh so um and he's one month old is that
how old he is no so he's actually one
years old now one year old now okay my
daughter is is two years old okay um
what time actually i don't know if you
know or not but i had a crazy story that
you know i actually deliver my son
during training camp last year okay now
um you had us at that hello
um okay kevin say what what happened
what happened yeah so
i'm gonna try to keep it short because
it's def obviously it's the law throwing
our story yes
yes it sounds like it on its face so
what happened we actually i said this is
during training camp and obviously we
knew my wife's about to be due my wife
was actually going to be due on the 24th
of august and this was the 20 i think it
was the 22nd that's actually so it's
another 22nd she's having contractions
and i'm like okay just tonight he's
going to come a day early and the
contractor stopped long story short i
went to sleep
she's yelling crying but i'm like i'm
asleep obviously it's like 10 o'clock
and woke up and my wife is
you know kevin kevin kevin so i'm
hearing faint voices in the back in the
background so i actually finally got up
she's in the bathroom she's having
contractions her water had broke so we
get up
her mom was downstairs she was staying
with us as well
and i had to come upstairs to help her
get dressed help her get ready so i'm
running down up and down the stairs
getting the car ready run the car seat
in the car
come back upstairs
she's she was getting up putting her
clothes on i come back upstairs and
she's literally back on the ground like
on her hands and knees by the bed it's
go time
it's go time she can't move oh my god
it's like the baby's coming and i'm
thinking in my head like this is no way
this is about to happen like you just
gotta get you to the car the hospital
five minutes up the street we'll be fine
so i'm like okay well let me go back
here because obviously she had her pants
on so let me just want to take a peek
because she said she's like the babies
come i just want to see
and i look back there and the head is
already coming out come on dude the head
is coming out and so
i didn't have no time to panic i just
had to get back there and i mean luckily
we had a doula that was on the phone
that was actually on our way to our
house okay but i had on the phone so she
kind of walked me through everything but
man it was one of the craziest things
that ever happened with me and my wife
and i mean i pretty much
it's funny i always say that uh last
last season i only caught one
interception last year but it was
actually two
that was probably my greatest
intercession i ever caught amazing
oh my god talk about being alone on an
island there's a defensive back huh i
mean my gosh is that technically an
interception though that's the same team
uh that is it's true that's true it's a
reception i would imagine that's true
that's the same team well done tj yeah
wow
okay yes sir
i got to give all credit to my wife even
though i respected
everything of course i mean of course it
was it was wild
i would say so boy that's the that that
puts the legacy in the family legacy
fund i'll tell you that hey you're right
about that oh my gosh
um what a pleasure to have you on um
good luck the rest of the way let's uh
let's reconnect please as you go about
your business i appreciate you i
appreciate you having me on the show
okay and and when you when when you say
national media doesn't pay attention
whatever just you can't paint us all
with the broad brush okay we're not all
the same is what i'm saying you're right
about that rich you've always been a
good guy okay you've always been like
you've always been on a good team i
appreciate
i appreciate that uh have a good rest of
your monday let's chat again soon hi
rich hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here